the Detroit Pistons included health care
benefits for Monty Williams's wife when
he signed to become the Pistons next
head coach and that act of kindness
played an enormous role in Williams's
decision to sign his wife Lisa has been
courageously battling breast cancer
throughout his time coaching and the
severity of her health almost deterred
him from accepting the Pistons job but
they waited for him not only did the
Pistons show an incredible amount of
patience as Williams decided whether or
not to take the job offer but they also
included compassionate and generous
additions to his contract specifically
with his wife and mine along with
provided Health Care to help his wife
Lisa the Pistons are also making
Williams the League's highest paid coach
they also granted him access to the
private jet so he could conveniently
travel for coaching purposes and to be
home by Lisa